jean pierre chevènement repris ses
fonctions au ministère de l'intérieur ce
matin quatre mois après son accident
d'anesthésié il était très entouré car
chacun voulait figurer sur la photo près
du miraculé de la république reportage
armes boutet jacques gregor il était la
vedette du jour applaudi ce matin
partout le gouvernement place beauvau
c'était le grand retour de jean-pierre
chevènement avec les bises et les
cadeaux les sharp à rayures n'est pas
pour le ministre de l'intérieur mais ce
dernier affiche quand même un grand
sourire
l'émotion des retrouvailles traverse les
tables visiblement l'année commence
plutôt bien à 10 heures c'est
l'ouverture des grilles
tous les ministres prennent le chemin de
l'elysée en tête un homme vole la
vedette au chef du gouvernement
c'est jean pierre chevènement toutes les
questions des journalistes sont pour lui
elle concerne son état de santé je vais
aussi bien que possible merci et
je peux vous dire que mes globules
rouges sont au rendez vous que je la
relaye vite ces assemblées frère
ces quatre mois d'absence ont mis en
lumière tout son poids politique au sein
du gouvernement
jean pierre chevènement va s'atteler à
plusieurs dossiers comme la montée de la
violence qui préoccupe le chef de l'état
pour la cérémonie des voeux
jacques chirac retrouver donc jean
pierre chevènement pour la première fois
depuis son hospitalisation
il est vrai que je veux dire je l'avais
vu au val de grâce c'était le 4 octobre
allez faut que je ne pouvais plus me
servir de mes jambes j'ai fait l'effort
à l'époque surhumain de me lever ce
qu'est mon premier exercice définitif
thérapie depuis son voyage comme il
l'appelle jean pierre chevènement se dit
à la fois identique est différent dans
la rue l'homme attire les regards et les
objectifs
il le sait alors il en joue non sans
humour les offert mal à lui faire mal
regardez ouverte quoi vous reculez
voilà merci